[Music]
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight two years ago this month
right before the last presidential
election the 2020 election we
interviewed a former business partner of
the Biden family's name was Tony
bobolinski and he told us a remarkable
story Joe Biden's son and his brother
had entered into highly lucrative deals
with foreign governments including the
communist government of China in which
they sold access to the United States
government in exchange for millions of
dollars for themselves now in many
levels that was a crime Joe Biden was
aware of it when it happened and Joe
Biden profited from it directly
it was a strong charge to make but Tony
bobolinski had the documents the emails
and the text messages to prove that it
happened
we considered it a huge story and we
spent an hour on it in October of 2020.
two years later we still consider it a
huge story yet in all of that time no
other major news organization in this
country has bothered to follow up
the New York Times never interviewed
Tony bobolinski as part of an
investigation into the Biden family
business deals which is strange because
he was a partner with the Biden family
but then neither has the Washington Post
now they have the other television
networks they've ignored it
the FBI whose job it is to enforce
federal law did take a lengthy statement
from Tony bobolinski back in 2020 and
during that conversation he outlined
several felonies the bidens had
committed and he would know because he
saw it and then he provided extensive
documentation to prove that it happened
the agency spoke to seemed shocked and
they promised to get back to Bob olinski
for a follow-up interview but they never
did in fact the FBI never called Tony
bobolinski again
no one was ever indicted for these
crimes the investigation into them was
squelched to this day the FBI continues
to suppress evidence proof that the most
powerful family in the country
has committed crimes against the United
States
that is the definition of corruption
it's unacceptable if the United States
is going to continue as a Democratic
Republic we can't have this it cannot go
on
next month voters will have a chance to
change course they will have the chance
to repudiate the forces that have
dangerously politicized and corrupted
our law enforcement agencies
before voters make that decision we
thought it was important that they hear
once again from Tony bobolinski over the
last two years he has learned quite a
bit more about the business dealings the
criminal business dealings of the Biden
family so for the next hour we're going
to bring you our recent conversation
with Tony bobolinski we're going to
begin tonight with his first hand
experience with the FBI's cover-up of
what the Biden family was doing
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight